[Musica]
Grazie Marta grazie Desiree Grazie a
tutti voi
la mia storia il viaggio che facciamo
assieme parte da una lampadina a LED la
tecnologia a led è stata scoperta nel 62
da un fisico nei colonian e sviluppata
poi in modo industriale nel 68 Ma le
prime lampadine facevano solo una luce
rossa e successivamente sono migliorate
ma rimanevano comunque troppo costose
all'inizio degli anni 2000 hanno sono
riusciti a trasformare lampadine e a
farne una luce bianca ma il prezzo
dissuadeva la gran parte delle persone
dall'acquistarla e solo dopo con un
successivo innovazione tecnologiche il
prezzo è crollato e oggi tutti noi
compriamo solo lampadine a LED la nei
negozi si vendono soltanto lampadine non
la lampadina a fluorescenza perché erano
importanti le lampadine perché
consumavano più o meno un decimo
dell'energia
delle lampadine fluorescenze lampadine
tradizionali
sarebbe stato quindi importante
utilizzare anche in termini di risparmi
queste queste lampadine e mettevano
quindi un decimo delle missioni di gas
serra delle lampade tradizionali ma
costavano troppo quando il prezzo è
collato quando l'innovazione ha permesso
al prezzo di scendere sono diventate
quelle che usiamo tutti perché parto da
questo esempio perché è quello che sta
succedendo oggi per molte altre
tecnologie è il punto di svolta che ci
permette di guardare al tema di
cambiamenti climatici in un modo
completamente diverso perché il
cambiamento climatico se parlato spesso
con superficialità di ignoranza Quando
si sente dire ma è sempre accaduto è un
fenomeno naturale ci adatteremo
pure con indifferenza Quando qualcuno
dice ci sono altre priorità ci abbiamo
l'inflazione l'economia l'emigrazione
e qualche volta anche con angoscia se tu
nei giovani che
consci dei problemi delle difficoltà
delle conseguenze a volte catastrofiche
dei cambiamenti climatici fanno hanno
difficoltà nell'immaginare il loro
futuro si chiedono ma a un senso avere
un figlio compare una casa quando ci
aspetta un mondo come quello che è
conseguenza anche meno climatico e io
vorrei invece dargli un punto di vista
un po' diverso perché quello che sta
succedendo nel mondo della tecnologia e
dell'economia i grandi stravolgimenti
che sono avvenuti negli ultimi 10 anni
ci permettono di affrontare il
cambiamento climatico da una prospettiva
diversa
Forse più ottimistica certamente diversa
e ci permettono quindi di immaginare il
cambiamento climatico come
un'opportunità un'opportunità per un
modello di sviluppo diverso una crescita
economica diversa
soprattutto nei paesi in via di sviluppo
dove le conseguenze sono più rilevanti e
dove la disponibilità di energia a basso
costo in quantità quasi illimitate
permetterà una crescita economica un
livelli di istruzione miglioramento
della sanità una disponibilità di cibo
come mai hanno avuto in quei in quei
paesi ma anche noi nel beneficeremo per
cui la domanda è ma è possibile oggi
fermare il cambiamento climatico o
controllare dedurre le emissioni in modo
da evitare le conseguenze più
catastrofiche la risposta è sì possiamo
ancora farlo e possiamo farlo proprio
perché sono avvenuti dei cambiamenti a
livello tecnologico e ed economico
L'esempio delle lampadine di prima
abbiamo bisogno di entrambe le
dimensioni una tecnologia che sia
disponibile a bassi costi in modo a
diventare pervasiva così come è successo
per le lampadine a LED ed è quello che
sta succedendo oggi per molte altre
tecnologie di cui abbiamo bisogno
azzerare le missioni In tempi rapidi il
nostro viaggio quindi lo cominciamo
dalla consapevolezza dell'importanza di
quello che sta succedendo e del problema
che dobbiamo che dobbiamo affrontare e
poi
Passeremo un po' la volta a capire quali
sono le soluzioni che oggi abbiamo a
disposizione e che rendono la
transizione verso uno Shazam emissioni
conveniente anche dal punto di vista
economico e quindi il mondo lo
cambieremo non soltanto perché sappiamo
che dobbiamo difendere noi umani dai
rischi di enormi rischi che siamo
correndo ma anche perché c'è una
convenienza economica a farlo oggi c'è
una convenienza economica a farlo
iniziamo il viaggio dalla consapevolezza
che il clima è già cambiato il clima lo
vediamo lo vediamo poco per la verità
perché alle nostre latitudini il
cambiamento è ancora piccolo altrove
nell'africa sul sahariana o nel sud est
asiatica I cambiamenti sono molto più
importanti Eppure anche da noi dalle
siccità le inondazioni dai problemi di
sicurezza alimentare Abbiamo sicuramente
i primi impatti dei cambiamenti
climatici ben presenti tra di noi e
perché sta succedendo perché abbiamo
creato A livello mondiale una situazione
in cui gli umani non hanno mai vissuto
prima Queste sono le concentrazioni di
CO2 degli ultimi 800 Milano Cioè tu è il
più importante dei dei gas serra per
800mila anni hanno oscillato tra 150 e
300 parti per
volume e quindi valore che con
oscillazioni Anche importanti non ha mai
superato le 300 parti negli ultimi 100
anni siamo saliti a 420 abbiamo superato
questi limiti che caratterizzavano il
nostro pianeta per 800 in realtà ben più
3 milioni di anni
e siamo saliti a 420 non era mai
successo prima Qual è l'implicazione
l'indicazione è che la temperatura è
salita vedete negli ultimi 10 mila anni
l'ultima Era Glaciale è data da 20.000
anni fa negli ultimi 10.000 anni da
quando si sono sviluppate le civiltà
umane le temperature oscillata Tra meno
5 -05 + 0,5 rispetto alla media
terrestre
ed è rimasta lì oscillando mai superando
di mezzo grado il valore medio negli
ultimi 100 anni siamo saliti e adesso
siamo arrivati a un grado e due al di
sopra sembra poco ma in realtà è
tantissimo non era mai successo prima è
una lo dicevo una selva oscura un mondo
ignoto in cui non abbiamo mai vissuto
gli umani non sono mai non ho mai
abitato in un'atmosfera in un pianeta
con un'atmosfera di questo tipo
e alcuni di questi cambiamenti sono
irreversibili guardate la temperatura ad
esempio la temperatura oggi è cresciuta
di un grado 2 e qualsiasi cosa facciamo
nei prossimi 30 anni anche se
azzerassimo le missioni domani
arriveremo a un grado e mezzo di
incremento la temperatura terrestre nel
2034 solo un anno fa pensavamo nella
saremmo arrivati al 2040 un grado e
mezzo invece purtroppo l'andamento è
così rapido ed esponenziale che
arriveremo nel 2003 qua 34 un grande e
mezzo quello che possiamo fare è tentare
di fermarci lì di non salire troppo
rispetto a questo mezzo ma lì
Sicuramente arriveremo Quindi dovremo
affrontare un clima diverso In ogni caso
e il livello del mare uguale qualsiasi
scenario futuro anche il più positivo
anche quello in cui riuscissimo ad
azzerare emissioni implicherà un aumento
del medio del livello del mare di 50 cm
e dovremo Quindi anche a questo
adattarci non abbiamo alternative quello
che possiamo fare è non andare oltre
limitare il cambiamento a questa
dimensione perché altrimenti i
cambiamenti diventano troppo importanti
troppo pericolosi troppo rischiosi per
le nostre società
siamo sulla traiettoria giusta non Tanto
è vero che guardate la linea nera ci fa
vedere come le missioni sono cresciute
negli ultimi 30 anni in modo
regolare senza senza interruzioni ma
qualcosa stiamo facendo Ci sono degli
accordi internazionali ci sono delle
decisioni prese collettivamente che
avranno delle implicazioni importanti ma
insufficienti stabilizzeranno le
emissioni la linea rossa che vedete
quassù ci fa vedere come le missioni
saranno stabilizzate e ci porteranno a
un incremento di temperatura di circa 3
gradi
non è quello il nostro obiettivo non può
esserlo perché di conseguenze sarebbero
estremamente gravi Non solo per le
nostre popolazioni ma per popolazione di
tutto il pianeta e la traiettoria invece
che dovremo seguire per limitare le gli
incrementi di temperatura e quella che
vedete in verde in blu quella che le due
traiettorie identificano riduzione
compatibile con il grado e mezzo oppure
con i due gradi quindi dobbiamo stare in
mezzo a quelle due traiettorie ma vedete
che in entrambi i casi le missioni
devono ridursi rapidamente drasticamente
e rapidamente da qui al 2050 al 2060
insomma questo è il nostro Orizzonte
temporale Come fare le soluzioni le
conosciamo le soluzioni le tecnologie le
abbiamo qui l'agenzia internazionale per
l'energia rinnovabili ci dà delle
indicazioni un quarto delle 40 giga
tonnellate di CO2 che produciamo ogni
anno le cui possiamo eliminare con le
rinnovabili un altro quarto migliorando
movimento energetica un altro 20% con
l'elettrificazione un 10% ci verrà
dall'uso dell'idrogeno il resto
assorbendo CO2 ritirando CO2
dall'atmosfera Questo è quello che
conosciamo le tecnologie per farlo le
abbiamo ma dobbiamo
svilupparle implementarle realizzarle
molto più rapidamente di quello che
stiamo facendo ora ad esempio il solare
e le eolico sono tecnologie che
conosciamo Oggi però non ne abbiamo
abbastanza dovremmo da qui al 2030
moltiplicare per 4 le installazioni se
vogliamo perseguire quella traiettoria
che vi ho indicato prima di riduzione
quella verde o quella blu che vi ho
indicato prima gli auto elettriche
dovremmo moltiplicare per 18 il numero
di auto elettriche stiamo parlando di
numeri A livello mondiale ma il
moltiplicatore lo potete applicare anche
a livello nazionale quindi questo
incremento rapidissimo così come
Dovremmo accelerare l'efficienza
energetica quindi miglioramenti e di
energetica rispetto a quel 2% che oggi è
il nostro Tasso annuale di miglioramento
dovremmo raddoppiarlo e arrivare a un 4%
di miglioramento per anni oppure le
pompe di calore ce ne sono 53 milioni
negli edifici oggi e dovremo invece
arrivare al 2030 a 142 milioni sempre a
livello mondiale non sono cose
impossibili ma
richiedono uno sforzo importante in
termini di investimenti e in termini di
realizzazione tecnica di questi di
questi obiettivi Che cos'è che rende
possibile un cambiamento di questo tipo
il fatto che negli ultimi 10 anni i
prezzi di tutte queste tecnologie sono
crollati E questo che cambia un po' la
storia prima il costo era un ostacolo il
costo era il motivo per cui si diceva Ma
fondo i danni arriveranno nel futuro e
oggi invece devo pagare dei costi che
sono più elevati rispetto alle
tecnologie tradizionali basate sui
combustibili fossili oggi non è più così
guardate i prezzi delle rinnovabili sono
crollati
dell'85% in soli 10 anni per il solare
del 68 per isolare concentrazione per il
56% per
l'eonico E questa fortissima riduzione
dei costi fa sì che oggi il costo di
produrre l'energia elettrica con queste
soluzioni sia inferiore a produrre il
corso energia elettrica con i
combustibili fossili ed è per questo che
l'anno scorso
l'85% di tutta l'energia prodotta nel
mondo viene da rinnovabile e non viene
più da combustibili fossili di tutta la
nuova energia Quindi tutti i nuovi
impianti hanno queste caratteristiche
i prezzi delle batterie Guardate cosa è
successo in soli 10 anni ai prezzi delle
batterie 89% in meno e quindi di fatto
15 16 volte in meno il prezzo che
avevano 10 anni fa
E se qualcuno vieta Sì certo Ma le
batterie costano meno sono convenienti
Ma implicano altri problemi perché il
litio il cobalto sono materiali rari Beh
ci sono oggi altre soluzioni basate su
materiali diversi che stanno arrivando
sul mercato non sono distanti parliamo
di batterie allo stato solido batteria
al sale non sono un sogno questa è la
prima auto che funziona e già circola
con batterie al sodio è una seoul che è
una marca joint venture della Volkswagen
assieme al Jack che una che una fabbrica
cinese e già ci ricorda per le strade
della Cina per il momento in molte altre
soluzioni come delle batterie
estremamente più potenti più concentrate
di quelle che oggi conosciamo saranno
sul mercato nel 2024 2025 quindi il
futuro è già qui dei prezzi stanno
crollando ancora di più Vi faccio vedere
qui anche delle
ragazzi Ragazzi
Italiani che stanno lavorando su un
progetto fidanzata con Commissione
Europea per sviluppare un po' più in là
negli anni una batteria organica che non
avrà più bisogno nemmeno di tutti questi
materiali peraltro alcuni come il sodio
largamente disponibili e Dimenticavo
parlavo prima del led Guardate cosa è
successo ai prezzi ai costi delle
batterie delle luci a led delle
lampadine a LED anche in questo caso il
prezzo è diminuito di 15 volte in soli
10 anni di fatto azzerato Ecco questo è
il grande cambiamento in cui stiamo
vivendo e quel cambiamento che ci
permette di dire il costo non è più una
scusa per dire che le cose non si
possono fare è vero servono grandi
investimenti ma anche quelli stanno
arrivando e stanno arrivando a tratti
dalla Convenienza economica
Questa è la crescita degli investimenti
in soluzioni
emissioni zero Quindi quelle che aiutano
la transizione energetica e climatica
negli ultimi 10 anni vedete come nel
2022 abbiamo superato il trilione di
dollari investiti in
trasporti elettrificati in rinnovabili
in soluzione di idrogeno e così via un
trilione più di un trilione di dollari
già investito non è sufficiente Ma la
convenienza economica sta tirando
rapidamente la crescita di questi
investimenti Quindi anche i mercati
finanziari hanno capito che questa è la
direzione da perseguire cosa otteniamo
da queste riduzioni Qual è il beneficio
il beneficio non è soltanto fermare di
impatti dei cambiamenti climatici non è
soltanto evitare le conseguenze più
catastrofiche di cui vi ho parlato prima
c'è anche qualcosa di più avremo città
più pulite perché con la diffusione di
auto elettriche la qualità
dell'aria delle nostre città e quindi le
malattie le condizioni di asma diffusi
in anziani i bambini si ridurranno
grandemente avremo produzioni alimentari
più resilienti e meno costosi avremo
forniture energetiche più sicure e non
dipendenti da qualche paese straniero di
poca stabilità politica
e nell'insieme e su questo c'è un grande
consenso i costi del non fare i costi
dell'inazione saranno ben superiori dai
costi del fare dai costi della
transizione proprio per la convenienza
la nuova Convenienza economica dei costi
della transizione
Voi direte bello tutto facile perché non
si è fatto prima se tutto fosse come vi
ho raccontato io perché siamo così
indietro perché siamo così in ritardo
Beh
motivo ve l'ho detto un cambiamento il
cambiamento grande recente il crollo dei
prezzi recente Quindi adesso si sta
mettendo negli ultimi 5 anni è
cominciata una trasformazione importante
a livello a livello planetario però ci
sono altri motivi altri ostacoli che
rimangono e altre sfide che dobbiamo
superare perché tutto questo processo si
acceleri Innanzitutto
è bello dire che conviene il problema è
che non conviene a tutti ci sono alcuni
settori che saranno impattati
negativamente da altri che sono in patta
di positivamente alcuni che
guadagneranno altri che vedranno alcuni
lavoratori che perderanno il lavoro e
altri che invece lo guadagneranno o ce
ne saranno di nuovi
i costi di investimento iniziale saranno
ripagati dai benefici di queste nuove
soluzioni tecnologiche ma l'investimento
iniziale per certe famiglie potrebbe
essere troppo gravoso dottor famiglie
con redditi più bassi Quindi queste
potrebbero
opporsi o vedere con riluttanza il
cambiamento che noi siamo immaginando a
livello internazionale non tutti i paesi
avranno gli stessi benefici non tutti i
paesi hanno le stesse disponibilità e
capacità tecnologiche e quindi anche lì
non tutti saranno favorevoli e una
transizione in tempi In tempi rapidi
c'è un problema distributivo la torta si
ingrandisce Ma viene distribuita in modo
ineguale e questo fa sì che la
resistenza al cambiamento possa
manifestarsi Nonostante la convenienza
che
queste trasformazioni tecnologiche
stanno creando è un problema politico un
problema ridistributivo diventa un
problema politico e quindi Chiama in
causa i nostri leader i nostri leader
politici la capacità di questi vie di
guardare lontano e di mettere in pratica
politiche siano in grado di accompagnare
questo cambiamento la transizione perché
conviene Ma perché deve convenire a
tutti o comunque compensare quelli a cui
non conviene e quindi l'azione l'azione
necessaria in fondo questi A questo
servono i Ted a creare consapevolezza
per trasformare in azione l'azione
necessaria è un'azione che chiami in
causa le imprese Innanzitutto hanno il
gioco più facile No conviene e quindi
investano guadagnano trasformano però
non siamo come nelle lampadine a LED
alla fine del percorso per molte
tecnologie c'è ancora da fare c'è ancora
da innovare abbiamo ancora delle
soluzioni da cercare e i cui costi
devono devono ridursi
i consumatori i consumatori pure devono
cominciare a scegliere in modo più
consapevole il cambiamento climatico
dovrebbe essere la bussa delle loro
scelte quando compro qualcosa o quando
decido dove mettere i miei risparmi devo
scegliere sulla base delle conseguenze a
chi vanno i miei risparmi a qualcuno che
inquino o qualcuno che gestisce la
transizione quando compro un prodotto
quali sono le conseguenze di
quell'acquisto o come viene prodotto
nella vita civile quando vado a votare
chi scelgo qualcuno che sa guidare
questa transizione o qualcuno che invece
la ostacola
e poi la politica la politica ha un
ruolo importante deve inventarsi
soluzioni nuove abbiamo detto i corsi di
investimento iniziali sono importanti e
poi la convenienza economica di ripaga
Ma allora dobbiamo aiutare la fase
iniziale la fase di avvio negli Stati
Uniti hanno scelto un sistema di sussidi
diffuso per farlo potremmo immaginare
soluzioni diverse per esempio dei
sistemi di finanziamento a tasso zero in
cui il costo per lo stato è soltanto
l'interesse non pagato ma invece di
finanziamento viene rimborsato nel tempo
attraverso i benefici addizionali che le
nuove soluzioni i costi minori che le
nuove soluzioni producono quindi ci sono
le possibilità ci sono le possibilità e
il cambiamento di cui ho parlato questo
questa novità in termini di convenienza
economica della transizione è un
elemento importante ma non è sufficiente
non è sufficiente Pur tuttavia Sì
possiamo riuscirci
possiamo riuscirci perché abbiamo gli
strumenti per farlo siamo stati la causa
del problema e adesso possiamo essere la
soluzione
[Applauso]